ah
soy científica
o sí
el otro día estaba en una manzana ahora
espera en la sala de espera que más bien
debería llamarse sala de desespera de un
sanatorio mientras esperaba mi atención
fluctuaba entre mis acciones laborales y
las voces que escuchaban
no no esas voces no eran alucinaciones
esas voces eran conversaciones de gente
random que estaba en la misma sala de
espera que yo haciendo lo mismo que yo
es decir esperando les habrá pasado de
escuchar esas voces cierto
notaron que en esas salas de espera
personas totalmente desconocidas hasta
entonces
empiezan a conversar y comparten relatos
sobre sus enfermedades orgánicas o
físicas
comparten todo tipo de detalles sobre
estas enfermedades orgánicas o físicas
que padecen con estas otras personas
desconocidas y de hecho reciben reacción
es súper empáticas de esas personas pero
notaron también que en esas mismas salas
de espera en rara ocasión o casi nunca
solemos escuchar decir cosas como tengo
trastorno depresión mayor
tengo trastorno bipolar
tengo ansiedad
tengo esquizofrenia o cosas similares
de hecho en esas salas de espera
cuando se abre la puerta de un
consultorio digamos por ejemplo de
cardiología y sale la médica cardióloga
y llama a juan de los palotes porque su
turno para ser atendido la actitud de
juan es la de decir sí soy yo acá estoy
y se levanta todos contentos para entrar
el consultorio porque su turno y las
personas desconocidas con los que
conversaba hasta entonces le dan
alientos que le dan palmaditas en la
espalda y por poco le lanzan brillitos
en cambio cuando en esa misma sala de
espera la puerta que se abre es la de un
consultorio de salud mental
y se escucha decir juan de los palotes
está
la actitud de juan es casi la de decir
hable más bajito no diga mi nombre tan
fuerte
si pudiera juan capaz que le diría
entremos corriendo al consultorio y nos
escondamos o fijamos que no nos
conocemos
lo que sucede en la sala de espera en
este caso también es diferente esas
personas desconocidas voltean a mirar de
quién se trata quién entra a ese
consultorio
no hay alientos no hay palmaditas no hay
brillitos
lamentablemente casi todo lo contrario
en la mayoría de las ocasiones
a esas personas desconocidas casi que
parece que las une el espanto los
prejuicios sobre las enfermedades
mentales para decirlo todo
por qué
soy cecilia lópez steinmetz y como les
mencioné soy científica soy doctora en
psicología entre otras cosas y mi
pregunta es por qué por qué no nos
animamos a hablar de las enfermedades
mentales con la misma naturalidad que lo
hacemos al hablar de las enfermedades
físicas
acaso uno de los motivos sea porque
pensamos que las personas normales y en
completo estado de bienestar existen en
algún lugar
pues sí ese es uno de los motivos les
tengo noticias
las personas normales no existen
ah
ustedes creen que si ustedes están
seguros que sí
ustedes tienen certeza de que las
personas normales si existen que las ven
que las escuchan que hablan con ellas
que se reúnen con ellas ok
pues en ese caso tengo que decirles que
ustedes están alucinando o bien
delirando
si ustedes padecen estos u otros
síntomas relacionados con trastornos
mentales es necesario que realicen una
consulta con un profesional de la salud
mental está muy bien y es natural hacer
esa consulta
las salas de espera de un sanatorio son
lugares donde las personas estamos ahí
encerradas con incertidumbres sin saber
cuánto va a durar eso con la sensación
de que va a durar un rato largo y
expuestas a poco o casi ningún estímulo
el año pasado atravesamos una situación
similar a la de la sala de espera solo
que si las personas extrañas
desconocidas ahí presentes la
atravesamos en casa
claramente me estoy refiriendo a la
medida sanitaria de cuarentena
establecida en argentina en respuesta a
la pandemia de kobe 19 y les hablo de
argentino porque vivimos aquí pero sepan
que a finales de marzo de 2020 un tercio
de la población mundial estaba viviendo
en cuarentena esto quiere decir que la
cuarentena como medida sanitaria para
afrontar esta pandemia no fue como el
dulce de leche
es decir no fue un invento argentino
debido a la pandemia y a la medida
sanitaria de cuarentena tuvimos que
pasar mucho más tiempo en nuestra propia
compañía o con quiénes conviviera mos
según como hayamos interpretado todo
esto podríamos decir que experimentamos
una nueva forma de soledad o bien de
intimidad y proximidad la pregunta es
quiénes de ustedes estaban listos para
semejante cosa
pues bien la evidencia científica
disponible actualmente sugiere que la
mayoría de las personas no estábamos
preparadas
quizás les haya pasado a ustedes o no
pero durante la cuarentena
muchas personas empezaron a preocuparse
por la propia salud mental y la de sus
seres queridos fue un momento muy
extraño que decirlo donde de repente
muchísimas personas empezaron a notar
que la salud mental importa y que
síntomas relacionados con depresión
ansiedad fobias riesgo suicida consumo
nocivo de alcohol entre otros son algo
que nos puede pasar a todas las personas
incluso a aquellas que se creen
completamente normales o que tienen
certeza de que la normalidad existe a
ellas también les puede pasar
desde el laboratorio de psicología del
instituto de investigaciones
psicológicas de la universidad nacional
de córdoba y del conicet
iniciamos una serie de investigaciones
desde tres días antes del inicio de la
40 en argentina y las continuamos
durante las sucesivas extensiones de
esta medida sanitaria
en estas investigaciones nos preguntamos
cuál era el estado de salud mental de
las personas antes durante y una vez
finalizada esta medida sanitaria
con estas preguntas en mente y muchas
otras
realizamos mediciones de indicadores que
están relacionados con trastornos
mentales tales como depresión ansiedad
riesgo suicida consecuencias negativas
del consumo de alcohol entre otras bueno
claramente hoy no les puedo contar los
resultados de todas esas investigaciones
porque fueron un montón pero si puedo
contarles al menos un hallazgo llamativo
hablemos por ejemplo de estudiantes
universitarios
en ellos fueron llamativos los hallazgos
cuando medimos indicadores que se
denominan de malestar psicológico
general pero que están relacionados con
depresión y ansiedad
imaginen que teníamos dos grupos de
estudiantes universitarios
un grupo de estudiantes universitarios
que alguna vez en su vida habían
recibido un diagnóstico de trastorno
mental es decir que alguna vez en su
vida al menos habían padecido una
enfermedad mental y otro grupo de
estudiantes universitarios que nunca en
su vida habían tenido enfermedad mental
cuando estos dos grupos creen ustedes
que empeoró durante la cuarentena
les cuento
en el grupo de estudiantes
universitarios que alguna vez en su vida
había sido sido diagnosticado con un
trastorno mental cuando medimos estos
indicadores de malestar psicológico
general pero que les dije que se
relacionan con depresión y ansiedad lo
que encontramos fue que estos
indicadores se mantuvieron en niveles
estables durante la cuarentena
en niveles ciertamente elevados pero
estables esto quiere decir que no
empeoraron y mejoraron en cambio
en el grupo de estudiantes
universitarios que nunca en su vida
habían tenido una enfermedad mental es
decir aquellos que hubiésemos ubicado
dentro del grupo de los normales o
sanitos pues en ellos lo que encontramos
fue que la depresión y la ansiedad
aumentaron durante la cuarentena
les pasó a ustedes quizás que durante la
cuarentena se sintieron más tristes que
lo habitual más ansiosos que lo habitual
que quizás necesitaron dormir muchas más
horas que lo habitual o la inversa que
tuvieron más dificultades para conciliar
el sueño o incluso que consumieron
muchas más bebidas alcohólicas que las
que consumían antes de la cuarentena
quizás les haya pasado
bueno estos brevísimos resultados que
les acabo de contar muestran una vez más
que todas las personas podemos padecer
síntomas relacionados con trastornos
mentales o incluso padecer un trastorno
mental propiamente dicho
buena parte de lo que nos hace humanos
son nuestros pensamientos y nuestras
emociones
pero no solo cuando estos son bonitos
agradables positivos divinos fantásticos
sino también cuando se tornan un poco
más oscuros negativos depresivos
obsesivos fóbicos ansiosos lo que fuera
tengan en cuenta por ejemplo que el
estado de ánimo al igual que un
electrocardiograma no es una línea recta
plana
si lo fuese estaríamos muertos
en cambio el estado de ánimo se parece
más bien a ondas que fluctúan
dentro de ciertos rangos
pero que a veces pueden empezar a
fluctuar fuera de esos rangos y
generarnos sufrimiento malestar
síntomas o incluso constituir un
diagnóstico de trastorno mental
reconocerlo es el primer paso para
empezar a afrontarlo
para entonces tratarlo y entonces
resolverlo
luego si las invito a empezar a remover
prejuicios sobre las enfermedades
mentales y a reconocer en ustedes mismos
primero y en los demás luego también a
lo mental como parte de su estado de
salud total
empecemos por reconocer que la depresión
la ansiedad el riesgo suicida el
trastorno bipolar o cualquier otra
enfermedad mental son eventos que nos
pueden suceder a todas las personas pero
que esto no nos y no nos invalida no nos
anula ni nos descalifica como personas
exactamente del mismo modo que no nos
padecer un dolor de muelas una
enfermedad artrítica una enfermedad
cardiológica o cualquier otra enfermedad
de índole puramente físico u orgánico
vamos
empecemos a remover prejuicios sobre los
trastornos mentales
logremos que las camisas sean solo parte
de nuestro atuendo o look